There is no one in India more powerful than this man.
Victory to India!
Four years after leading his party to a spectacular general election win, Indian prime minister
Narendra Modi remains a favorite to win again
in 2019.
Modi travels the globe promoting a new modern
India, bear hugging world leaders along the way.
He tweets regularly to his 40 million followers
and even connects with supporters through an app named after him.
Prime Minister Modi and I are world leaders
in social media.
Still, Modi’s record is mixed.
There are questions about whether the ground
reality has changed much under his leadership.
And some of his biggest economic reforms have
caused confusion and disrupted the economy.
This is the story of how Narendra Modi is
trying to rebrand India as a modern economy
and how the reality does not always match
the rhetoric.
Since taking office in 2014, Modi has become
India’s “salesman in chief”.
He’s largely singing the same tune,
Iain Marlow covers Indian politics for Bloomberg
News in New Delhi.
Come invest in India.
Come start a business here.
Trade with us.
Buy Indian goods. Do yoga.
He openly courts countries like Japan, Israel
and Saudi Arabia and he’s gotten closer
to the US, even addressing a joint session
of congress in 2016.
To all of these countries, his message is
the same.
India is now the fastest growing large economy
with the most open investment climate.
It’s not just a dusty place where people
hang off the sides of trains.
It's a new modern economy.
It's the skyscrapers in Bombay. it's the start-ups
in Bangalore.
Modi came into power with the reputation
of being a pro-business reformer.
For 13 years he was the chief minister of
the western state of Gujarat where he presided
over more than a decade of rapid economic
growth.
His policies became known as the ‘Gujarat
model” and they were the promise of what
he might do for India.
But his economic policies have gotten mixed
reviews.
On the plus side he’s opened millions of
bank accounts for the poor, attracted more
foreign direct investment and India has eclipsed
China as the world’s fastest growing major economy.
He’s also seen a number of setbacks.
In November 2016 Modi surprised the nation
by banning 86 percent of India’s cash overnight.
The 500 rupee and 1,000 rupee currency notes
presently in use will no longer be legal tender
from midnight tonight.
It was as if the US banned the $20 and $100
bills overnight.
The idea was to tackle so-called black money,
a local term for cash stashed away to avoid taxes.
A lot of poor people thought he was hitting
the rich and then you had his critics who
said, oh my god, what are you doing?
You just eliminated the vast majority of cash
in a country that basically only operates on cash.
The day after people lined up outside banks
to deposit their money.
And small businesses didn’t know how to
pay their workers.
It caused India’s expansion to slow to a
three-year low.
Then in June 2017 Modi introduced a national
sales tax, called the goods and services tax, or GST.
The goal of the GST was to unify India’s
complicated tax structure and make it easier
to do business, but …
In some cases, the tax rates were really confusing.
Say one nut, a cashew, would attract a different
tax than an almond or a peanut.
So, if you had a bag of mixed nuts, what was
the tax rate?
Nobody knew how to do business.
People stopped buying things.
The economy basically seized up.
While the cash ban and GST have not been economically
beneficial in the short term, they still helped
build Modi’s reputation as an authoritative
leader.
There’s no single reason for Modi’s enduring
popularity.
On the political side, the Hindu nationalist
agenda of his Bharatiya Janata party, or BJP
has made him electorally successful but
it also makes him controversial.
There are parts of the population that will
never forgive Modi for his handling of the
2002 gujarat riots which killed as many as
2000 people, mostly Muslims.
A lot of human rights organizations accused
the government at the time, which was run by Modi.
It actually Lead to Modi being denied a US
visa.
But he was eventually cleared of any wrongdoing.
More recently, he has come under fire for
failing to quickly condemn attacks by Hindu nationalists on Muslims.
Members of his own party have even supported
people accused of raping and killing a young Muslim girl.
So while India has moved up 30 places in the
World Bank's ease of doing business ranking
since Modi became prime minister,
Many of the problems that India is known for:
lack of infrastructure, poverty, malnutrition,
bad education system, bad health system
haven’t changed much.
What has changed to some extent, is the momentum
that people see around India.
Modi is trying to create an India that people
can believe in, that people can be hopeful about.
Modi remains India’s most popular leader.
Many Indians are likely to re-elect him in
2019 with the hope that changes will come
and it just takes time.